- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is pursue perfection
over you, Benedict Cumberbatch.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
♫ I wake every morning
- You can never perfect what we do.
There is no way, I've
never met anyone who goes,
"That's perfection."
I mean, to an audience,
outside of your work,
people can think that that's the only way
they'd ever want to see that part played
or that moment done, whatever,
but as an actor, and
this isn't mock humility,
I think it just go for
all art forms, really,
that the whole point is
perfection is unachievable.
So, it's that constant
pursuit of the unobtainable,
which is kind of magic, really.
And, should keep us kind
of motivated to try better,
it's the Beckett thing,
fail again, fail better.
- My unhealthy relationship
with perfection
cost me $40 million
when I was 22 years old.
I had my software
company, we were growing,
and we had this big vision
for what we could do.
We had this big business plan for
the types of companies that we could help.
And the flaw was, I wanted
to have the perfect plan.
And I spent an entire
summer working on the plan,
buildin' the plan, researchin' the plan,
and zero time actually
trying to execute the plan.
And, there came a time when I was 22
whe we had the opportunity
to sell our company.
And a big player was coming in.
They raised a huge
fund, like $800 million,
to go out and buy companies.
And they were looking at
our biggest competitor.
And then they started looking at us.
And we were late to the party.
We were a late throw-in.
And we weren't ready.
But we got to be number two,
it was between the two of us.
And they chose our competitor over us.
They chose our competitor
because they had more
of the plan worked out.
They were executing harder.
Where, for us, we had some
of the plan worked out,
but we hadn't done enough.
And so, we lost that deal,
and they bought our
competitor for $40 million.
And that stung.
That hurt.
That was a big loss for me,
I took that really hard.
And I realized if we just did
a better job of executing our plan,
if we didn't care about
reaching perfection,
if that wasn't our sole goal,
then maybe we would have got that deal.
That regret, that feeling like,
If I did things a little differently,
I probably could have got that deal.
And so, perfection is this funny thing.
Perfection is a great
thing to try to go after,
to try to reach, to
always try to get better,
but not let it hold you
back from doing something.
This plagues so many entrepreneurs.
So many wanna-be entrepreneurs.
You have an idea for what you want to do,
and so you're planning, planning,
planning, planning, planning,
and then you never do,
and then you miss your window.
You miss your window because
that opportunity has passed,
or some life event comes
up and distracts you,
or some other thing happens.
Like, you miss your window, it happened,
and then you see somebody else go out
and make tons of money and have
a huge impact that was your idea.
And you can't blame that person.
The only person you can blame is yourself
because you didn't do anything about it,
'cause you spent so long
planning and planning
and planning to get the perfect plan.
Understand that there is no
such thing as a perfect plan.
There is no such thing
as a perfect product,
there's no such thing
as a perfect service.
If you ever hit perfection,
go out and quit,
and go do something else,
'cause you've hit the highest.
It's never perfect.
And, that's also part of the fun.
Like, the struggle and the
strive to hit perfection
needs to be the game, not
just hitting perfection.
The struggle and the drive
to get better at what you do,
to make better videos,
to make a better service,
to have your customers
love you more is the game,
is what you should be loving
doing and working on improving.
And so, yes, you want to
try to pursue perfection,
understand you're never going to hit it,
and that's not only okay, it's great.
It's great to continue to have this goal
that you're shooting towards,
'cause once you hit a goal, you fall off.
You get depressed.
And, so, don't let that
pursuit of perfection
prevent you from taking action.
It's both.
It's take action and make it better.
It's start and improve.
Don't let that pursuit of perfection
prevent you from getting
started on your path.
Don't make that $40 million
mistake that I made,
and I learned my lesson on,
and I'm hopefully never
going to make again.
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious
are you a perfectionist and has it
held you back in your
life or your business?
Super curious to find out.
Leave it down in the comments below
and we'll join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Miguel Camara.
Miguel, thank you so much for pickin' up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
I really, really appreciate the support
and hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning.
For another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
♫ I wake up
Hi, Believe Nation, if you want to go
a little bit deeper into this topic
and learn more and get more context,
I'm adding in some extra bonus clips
that I think you'll enjoy.
- [Interviewer] With
Tesla, your goal has been
to make a better car and
you've done that with
an electric vehicle that people covet,
that has quite a cult
following, that's upgradeable,
but you also want to achieve,
and your turn of phrase
is very nice, or try to achieve this
platonic ideal of a car, right,
to reach perfection.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So, what does
the perfect car look like?
- Well, I mean, I do use that phrase
with our engineering science team,
that, aspirationally, we're in pursuit
the platonic ideal of a perfect car.
And, who knows what that
looks like, actually,
but it's, you want to
try to make every element
of the car as flawless as possible.
And, there'll always be
some degree of imperfection,
but try to minimize that and create a car
that is just delightful in every way,
and I think if you do that then
the rest kind of takes care of itself.
- My father worked two
jobs his whole life--
- [Interview] One was at a GM plant?
- Yes, GM plant
- And then a--
for 30 years, and then he
had trash-hauling service.
So he had his own truck and
we would go door to door,
pick up people's trash,
and was it was one situation where
it was probably seven below zero,
and very cold Saturday morning.
And, my job was to pick
up all the loose trash.
And, so, we, it was so cold that
I got everything that I could just grab,
throw it on the truck
and I ran to the truck
'cause it was just cold to jump in.
By the time I got in and the door shut,
my father opened it back up,
grabbed me and dragged me
through the snow, back
to the barrels, to say,
"Son, you did a halfway job.
"And, if you do this
job in a halfway manner,
"you're going to be a
halfway basketball player,
"you'll put in half the time,
"you'll only put in half
the time as a student."
And he said, "You're supposed
to do this job right,
"so I want you to go get that shovel,
"and I want you to chop the ice
"until you can get all the trash that's
trapped in the ice and
put it on the truck."
And that's what happened.
And, so, he taught me
how to be a perfectionist
and do everything the right way.
- So those are very important lessons.
- There's still things
that we very much believe.
The strive for perfection,
for being the best,
for only doing the best
products, for staying focused.
The fact that, despite
this table being so small
that you and I are sitting at,
you could put every Apple product on it,
every single one that we ship today,
and, yet, this year, our revenues
will be approximately 180 billion.
There's probably no other company
on the face of the Earth
that could say that.